i know i know i don't know how long
you've been waiting for this movie i've
been waiting for this movie for you know
life but first i want to thankfully
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by dr squatch dr
squatch is changing the way men approach
hygiene their shower soap leaves you
feeling refreshed feeling clean and that
clean is unnatural clean this soap
doesn't contain any of the harmful
chemicals a lot of other soap companies
use again they sent me soap but i
already buy their soap because i love it
even after all these months pine tar is
probably still my favorite of the scents
they don't just have soap they have
shampoo conditioner beard oil which is
the scent is crushed pine
apparently i like smelling like trees
it's a washingtonian thing that's how we
roll here so click the link below new
customers get 20 off of orders 20 more
by using promo code dsc john's thank you
once again to dr squatch for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it and now
the time has come
[Music]
so dune is directed by denny villeneuve
and it's a retelling of the story of
dune dune that classic sci-fi novel
that's hailed as the most important
sci-fi novel of all time dune that
classic 80 sci-fi movie that's classic
yet messy but i love it i don't care so
keeping it vague the story of dune is
pretty much
game of thrones galactic game of thrones
it's gonna say game of thrones in space
but it doesn't take place in space it
takes place on other planets so it's no
more in space than any story that takes
place on any other world doesn't make
sense so galactic game of thrones it
deals with houses and alliances and
backstabbing and schemes in this world
of galactic game of thrones there's this
desert planet called arrakis that has
the spice the spice is the most valuable
resource in the galaxy so house of
traders is essentially called upon to go
to the planet arrakis and then you just
start seeing the walls closing in
around the house atreides and then
schemes and loyalties and really evil
floaty bastards and holy man he was
menacing and the performances in this
movie like across the board everyone was
great you know they're going to be it's
a stacked cast with great actors in this
day and age you generally get two things
with that one a really boring floaty
head poster that looks really generic
but you gotta fit all the heads on there
because it's a stacked cast but also two
uh the performances in the movie are
epic and although it is a stacked cast
some you see more than others like
zendaya barely in the movie because it
is part one of two they divided the
story in two and this is only the first
of two movies that
hopefully happened javier bardem you see
more of him than zendaya but i like what
i saw josh brolin's grey jason momoa i
thought were there some people were like
whoa jason but he's i don't think he
fits but i thought his character brought
a lot of humanity and heart to the movie
that was necessary and it landed also
you get all those loving jason mamoa
body patch you can handle
but for the ones the movie really rests
on like the movie's on their shoulders
and you're with them for most of the
time timothy chalamet as paula tradies
and lady perfection herself playing lady
jessica that would be rebecca ferguson
the two of them it really is their movie
also stella skarsgard again wish i saw
more of him going to see more of him in
part two
but this dude every scene he's in scene
steeler there's not a lot of people he's
stealing scenes from but dude menacing
isn't really the word
just
ruthless son of a [ __ ]
every scene the kind of ruthless dick
that comes from you being the wealthiest
piece of [ __ ] in that galaxy but really
the treat the epic that this movie's
built around is the audio visual odyssey
that you're in for it's like every shot
denis villeneuve was like let's make
this
the greatest looking scene in existence
like from when the movie starts out you
see the spice harvesters on dune on
planet iraqis you're like
this looks way too good it doesn't stop
it from there it goes and oh also by the
way with all these epic visual shots can
we have hans zimmer work in the music to
create this
how to phrase it give me a second
orgasmic audio visual odyssey of
galactic proportions there you go that's
what this is
dune if you look up dune in the
dictionary it doesn't say this yet but
it should say orgasmic audio visual
experience of galactic proportions even
you match up the scenes from the 80s
dune movie it's like it there's no real
comparison you know like this just looks
so much
larger in scale epic and scope and it's
not just like oh the visuals are great
and that's that no the visuals are great
and that enhances the tension in certain
scenes the tragedy and other scenes when
you're dealing with a remake or a
retelling of a story rather since this
isn't really a remake of the 80s movie
it's a retelling of the book of dune i
don't get it just terminology when
you're doing that you have to justify
the movie's existence you know it's like
oh if we already have a dune movie why
does this exist and on every level it
justifies its existence and that's
really what i wanted from this movie you
know you have these things in your head
or at least i did where i had these
thoughts of like if a dune movie was
made now how epic would that be and i
can't say i thought of anything more
epic than this movie i thought it did a
good job catching you up to speed with
the politics of the galaxy and the
standing of certain houses and who hates
who and why and that comes from the fact
that it's longer than the old dune movie
but also only half the story you know
they're taking their time with it i will
say it probably would have served it
well to be an hbo max series or
something like that i think a series
dune lends itself to a series but we got
a movie all right but if you're matching
up the time the story of dunes gonna be
about five hours if it's two and a half
hours per half i loved this movie i
can't wait to see part two but my
enjoyment and how this movie
stands and sticks with me
hinges on whether or not part two's
gonna happen part two is not officially
announced it's just hope it happens if
this movie does well and you feel it
this doesn't feel like a complete movie
you know like when you're dealing with a
part one of something part one of two or
part one of three you can deal with it a
couple different ways you got it chapter
one right so it chapter one
felt like its own movie and if chapter
two happened great but if it didn't you
still had it chapter one which felt
complete in and of itself then you have
lord of the rings where lord of the
rings fellowship of the ring is part one
of three
and it has that cut off that you feel it
with that cut off at the end like whoa
it just kind of ends but if you look at
the beats of lord of the rings
fellowship of the ring it does still
have its three acts you know you have
your intro then you have act two and
then they go to the end fight in act
three then after that climactic and
fight then you get your cut off going oh
this isn't the end of the story there's
more to come then there's dune where
dune doesn't feel like it has three acts
it's act one going into act two end of
the movie hope part two happens so we
can see the conclusion but it might not
if part one doesn't do well
and that blows my mind but that's the
tricky thing i feel like i'm talking
about half of a movie in this review it
absolutely feels like half a movie
because it is half of a movie it's only
half the story that's how it's supposed
to be but now i'm here left reviewing
this movie going well if part two never
happens would i revisit part one again
because just feel like a waste of time
be cinematic blue balls that i just
don't want to experience i don't know
but as of right now because i'm just in
an optimistic mood i'm gonna go ahead
and be that optimist and say well part
two will happen this is just part one
and if i'm looking at part one and
that's pointing to part two we're gonna
have ourselves a [ __ ] epic dune epic
i could have phrased that better i'm not
refilming that anyhow if you're a dune
fan if it's your first time visiting
dune go for it go watch it it is a bit
of a slow burn in that denis villeneuve
kind of way but that's kind of what he
does but you're in for a visual treat
here man you're in for a movie that's
not a move that you watch it's a world
you experience that is to say for me
this dune movie was one of my favorite
cinematic experiences in the theater
this year and it is
awesome tacular
[Music]
i'll be honest with you
if dune part 2 doesn't happen
i'm going to lose it all right so dune
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you